こんにちははじめしたツアーですみなさんは line というものを使います
でしょうか
今の学生とかで普通の人は結構連絡をメールじゃなくてラインでよくしてると思うん
ですよあ髪の毛切りましたそこで僕は
line っていうのですねその普通にプっぽくなってこの文章打つのが一般的なん
ですけどまぁ4秒金はレアスタンプを使いますよね line スタンプっていうのを
作るんですけども僕の友達た僕も良いです
line のでスタンプ連打っていうのをするんです
特定の人にスタッフああああっめちゃくちゃおしまうって言ってそれはそれとかマジで
ラインがで小動きがすごい遅くなりこれじゃないかってくれたもにすぐ遅くなる時が
あって大画像や思ったわけですよ
こちらにはで line のグループをつくりました被験体が13人ぐらいです
メンバー13人ほど入れるチームを吐くなんですけどもこのチームのメンバーたちに僕
を言ってあります僕に
17時にもうすぐ10周年の17時に僕に1戦 line スタンプを連打してくると
言ってあります小銭僕にこの13にから一線にスタンプのライングレーターの届くと
そのライダーさんがねセンターと.ことによってライマー本当に壊れるのかどうか
line のアプリケーションの強さはね今が一番わかっていると思います
あと2分後ですね
も水 keter はいオッケーですこれでね大阪にが知りたいかというと
ラインも現在を知りたいと思ったわけなんですよ line というアプリの強さとか
そういうものが図れるというわけでございます
ただ実際に実験してみましょうあと1分後ですさあ果たして line スタンプ塗っ
て僕のラインは
ブックはられるかどうかという
ん
ございません
追いついてないようななかなか酷いん
どうなんだろう999食らった人がいてくれますね
また卵やでも動いています
これと.あれ
あれ月国の技術ともう
ひとまず泊まれましたね人なんですよね染まって何も聞かないんだけど
ってどういうこと花山完全に行ったらこれはほん事は初版これをしたらと思う
バッキーだ
扱わなくなっつっはって本当に使った
そうじゃない電源付け直そう
imo 落ちたのかな山へ落ちた落ちた落ちた
を伝え iphone 壊れちゃったのあのガチで落ちましたと思う
をしてもだってボタンを押す手を付かないんですよ
つかないんだよねこれ本当に壊れたのかな
あっつ開いて左手 the せない方でつかなくなりました
なカオスしても
のしません品ボタンを押しても何もなりません
おう
尻池助け
画面黒犬資料なるようんな
助けてっ
だめだ完全にダメだはいうんそれくらい line スタンプを連打すると
iphone は
ブックをれますみんな絶対真似しないようにねじゃん
すみません曲分かりますこっちがの